[Music]
hey guys what's up we are back with
another kaiju and monster video and this
one will be all about the kaiju of the
Pacific Rim universe in this video we
shall dive in into the weights of these
interdimensional monsters we will try to
assess and justify the reason as to why
the mouths of these kaiju are so light
as compared to the monster burst islands
for example the mega kg which is taller
and has more volume that Godzilla only
weighs 8 percent as much so before you
continue on with this video be sure to
like share and subscribe for more videos
and also check out our channel as we
have more than 70 videos and oh yeah
do smash the notification bell for
regular updates our new and upcoming
videos so let us get on with this video
about why the kaijus in Pacific Rim are
so lightweight and if they are realistic
let's start with an intro the kaiju are
a race of amphibious creatures
genetically engineered by the precursors
a sentient race from the anti vers kaiju
are colossal in size averaging hundreds
of feet tall and thousands of tons in
weight because of the tremendous
bolivars two brains are needed to
control the kaiju motor and cognitive
functions kaiju are highly aggressive
creatures especially when engaged in
combat however they work to a hive mind
system and the kaiju can communicate
instantly so which was the first guide
you well trespasser is the first guy to
emerge from the breach and attack
humanity in attack San Francisco on
August 10th 2013 and over the course of
6 days it destroyed 3 cities in a 35
mile long path of destruction before it
was finally killed by the United States
military and a British Royal Air Force
it stands taller or at level with a
Golden Gate Bridge and is strong enough
to tear through the structure apart with
its claws so in order of size the
smallest of course is baby
Itachi Kaju but out of the adult
specimens Karloff is the tiniest guide
you coming in and only several 90 tons
and a hundred and thirty feet tall then
comes meathead only Baba Itachi hardship
mutable trespasser and knife head with
weights between 2,000 and 3,000 tons
the ones about 3,000 tons are Haku juh
Shrek thorn ride you ridin ants gonna
the biggest of course our mega guide you
at more than seventy eight hundred tons
and sladden at more than 6,700 tons each
kaiju is classified into five different
categories category one and two
represented weakest of them while
categories three through five are
strongest it is not the weight or size
that determines categories the Serizawa
scale measures water displacement
toxicity and ambient radiation levels
given out by their bodies when they
passed through the breech the fluid
avocado is ammonia based and should they
be killed in combat their bodies are
triggered to self-destruct immediately
but why are they so lightweight when
compared to most of us kaiju like for
example the fourth category guide you
called Raichu was exactly as tall as
gods of 2014 but only weight three
thousand four and seventy five tons
while the g-man weighed 90 thousand tons
that is only three point eight six
percent as heavy I mean where that all
the mass disappear to being a creature
that big would have been at least 10 to
20 times heavier ass he officially
stated facts well let's learn more about
the square-cube law and how it relates
to kaiju so if we apply this law which
is basically states that if the volume
doubles then the mass triples to pacific
rim' kaiju then we get something like
this scale knife head down to two meters
for convenience we'll say that he is
really a hundred meters tall that's a
reduction of fifty times and then we
take the 50 and cubed we get a hundred
and twenty-five thousand next we divide
27 hundred tons of knife head by a
hundred twenty-five thousand and we get
a two meter too tall knife at weighing
only two point one six kilograms that's
light if we do the same that Godzilla
would have been around six hundred to
seven or eight kilograms for a height of
two meters one factor might be their
origins since they came from the anti
verse which is kind of like an alien
dimension their physiology would stem
from the physics of their world
we only know so little about this weird
realm of the precursors and the casual
but for one thing as seen in the ending
of the first movie the card creation
facility had a wheel surrounding that
allowed [ __ ] danger to float as if
very low low close to zero gravity well
the minimal gravity in that world would
have dictated that the creatures and
life-forms be a very light weight has
compared to animals and living things on
earth so according to the speed of [ __ ]
danger of falling in the anti verse it
would seem that the gravity in that
planet would have been around one-tenth
of that vert therefore the creatures
would also follow suit as being 1/10 or
less in weight as compared to Earthlings
but are they realistic if they had such
light materials and body mass would they
not crumble on earth and wouldn't Dave
struggle to even walk on a strange human
world with ten times the gravity as on
theirs well perhaps they have been
designed by the precursors aliens to
adapt quickly to this planet which will
also explain as to why the breach was
open underwater so as to allow them to
quickly add just to Earth's physics
another thing that might affect their
weight is that the kaiju are designed by
the precursors wood very lightweight but
super strong materials akin to the
real-world example of carbon fiber which
is stronger than steel but way lighter
the precursors with their advanced
technology must have utilised their
science to reconstitute Cardiff with
lightweight materials which would
explain the gap of questions between
volume and the weight of the kaiju
so that will explain why knife head was
only twenty seven hundred tons that's
like only forty m1a2 Abrams tanks and if
it was a monster first island and it
would weigh around 27,000 to 30,000 tons
and sladden would have been more than
70,000 tons as compared to his official
stated sixty seven hundred and fifty
tons and the mega kaiju would have been
more than 80 thousand tons which would
have sound more realistic given that
Godzilla 2019 weighs close to a hundred
thousand tons and the other titles like
Ghidorah we're a hundred forty thousand
tons seeming to be more believable
anyway it's been a blast bringing up
theories like DS and this brings us to
the end of the video but do you command
your thoughts in the comment section
below and do you like share and
subscribe for more related content on
kaiju monsters and more til next time